on va plus loin avec aujourd'hui à mes
côtés et l'imam directeur du mensuel
afrique magazine donjon en irak pour
soir face à vous bruno daroux de la
rédaction de france 24 bonjour brunoh
bonjour aux fans vous l'avez peut-être
suivi c'était il ya une heure environ
sur notre antenne jean yves le drian le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères s'est exprimé longuement sur
la crise qui secoue l'ukraine au
lendemain de négociations à istanbul où
d'aucuns ont cru voir une percée écoutez
ce qu'en pense le ministre français des
affaires étrangères est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes plus optimiste
est ce que vous voyez une éclaircie non
non dans la mesure où pour l'instant la
guerre continue je lui des propos je lis
des déclarations je ne vois pas date il
n'y a à ma connaissance aucune mesure de
retrait qui étaient prises à l'égard de
l'occupation par les forces armées
russes en ukraine la guerre continue à
kiev ait eu des bombardements cette
année la guerre continue année pro hl
daga continue à
kharkhiv la guerre continue à marioupol
qui devient une ville martyre où le
siège de marioupol décidée par le
président poutine abouti à ce qui y est
près de 200000 personnes qui sont prises
en otage la guerre continue jean yves le
drian qui ne fait là que constater
l'évidence bruno daroux et notamment sur
les deux villes sur lesquels les russes
avaient pourtant pris des engagements
hier kiev et yaniv oui alors il dit
qu'il ya pas de retrait en fait ce qui
s'est quand même passé hier on a vu des
mouvements de chars russes qui
regagnaient la biélorussie donc il ya eu
en tout cas c'est ce recul de certains
chars vers la biélorussie mais
effectivement les bombardements plus à
distance ont continué et sur kiev et
surtout j'avais effectivement toute la
question en fait c'est savoir s'il
s'agit d'un début de retrait on va dire
ou simplement d'aller en biélorussie
s'en servir comme base arrière en
quelque sorte pour un peu
recompléter les forces qui sont la seule
depuis 35 jours les hommes sont fatigués
les machines aussi donc voilà est-ce
qu'il s'agit d'un début de retrait ou
d'un repositionnement
d'abord d'une pause en fait pour les
machines et les hommes quittent ensuite
allé reconfigurer dans un nouveau
dispositif militaire peut être plus
comme d'ailleurs les russes n'ont pas
vraiment caché vers l'est et le sud est
notamment marioupol mais aussi le
donbass ou alors est-ce qu'ils vont
simplement marquer une pause et puis
revenir il n'ya pas effectivement là
jean yves le drian a raison il n'y a pas
de véritable retrait à proprement parler
des troupes russes de ce front nord
contrairement d'ailleurs à ce qu'avait
dit le vice ministre russe de la défense
hier à l'issue des négociations à
istanbul
et entre temps il ya une mise au point
du kremlin dmitri peskov 1 qui lui a
semblé effectivement beaucoup plus
pessimistes en coup droit ne voyant pas
de percée diplomatique
la france sur la même ligne que que les
etats-unis et le royaume-uni ziade à
doutant de la parole du kremlin
dorénavant dans cette affaire je sais
pas s'ils sont à 100% sur la même ligne
puisque par exemple les français ont
gardé un canal de discussion les
français n'utilisent pas les mêmes eaux
que joe biden sont peut-être pas aussi
en pointe que les anglais dans la
rhétorique guerrière extra donc macro et
cousines se sont parlé voilà donc il ya
des différences de j'allais dire de
gestion sur le fond je pense que tout le
monde est d'accord et ceux ci s'ils
avaient quelque chose à retenir de
l'intervention du ministre des affaires
étrangères c'est de dire un temps qu'il
n'y a pas d'actes il n'y a pas de
progrès donc pour le moment où il ya
aucun acte venant de la russie qui ce
qui justifierait un peu d'optimisme
deuxièmement il ya la question de
marioupol et là on voit que les français
sont très en pointe sur cette affaire
salaire il a dit ça arrive droit quatre
fois soul se sortir du siège couloirs
humanitaires les russes ne pratiquent
pas les couloirs humanitaires ils font
la guerre des ciel et il a cité la ville
plusieurs fois et la troisième dans le
troisième je sais qui il a quand même
posé les éléments du débat et ça montre
à quel point c'est une discussion et
négociation extrêmement complexe
question de la neutralité de l'ukraine
c'est quoi la neutralité l'ukraine c'est
quoi les garanties que pour aider nos
des exemptions dans tôt et les deux
journal je lui disais ça va être très
compliqué et très long et
il avait l'air de dire oui ça va être
très compliqué c'est ça va être long
donc du point de vue russe on voit pas
si on prend le point de vue russe ou en
tout cas le point de vue poutine avec un
certain cynisme on voit pas pourquoi on
arrêterait maintenant c'est à dire c'est
pas au moment où on est plutôt j'allais
dire en difficulté sur le terrain
militaire que qu'on n'a pas suffisamment
d'atouts dans sa main que l'objectif
c'est quand même probablement de casser
l'ukraine ou en tous les cas d'en faire
un état suffisamment affaibli donc on
voit pas pourquoi ils s'arrêteraient
maintenant et donc on voit bien cette
espèce de mécanismes de discussion
guerre discussions guerre qu'ils ont
appliqué en syrie qu'ils ont appliqué un
peu partout et ses illustrations
justement avec les propos de jean yves
le drian pourquoi lui ne croit pas au
portrait rue c'est bien il cite un
exemple de grozny et dalle est écouté et
des gardes et les guerres de siège sont
terribles on a une histoire des guerres
des sièges l'histoire c'est à la fois
grossemy et puis et puis alep où on a vu
je pense à à l'aide parce que j'ai été
en responsabilité à ce moment là où on a
vu la russie dit on va renégocier
et puis en fait la réalité c'était pour
reconstituer des forces donc on va voir
on va voir si le discours qui est tenu
va se manifester dans des actions
concrètes et donc
soit dans des retraits soit dans
l'annoncé d'un cessez le feu ce qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui c'est l'annoncé
d'un cessez-le-feu un barrio paul pour
éviter le carnage
c'est sur ce point que la russie sera
jugée sinon effectivement il pourrait
s'agir d'une simple manoeuvre pour comme
le dit jean yves le drian ont
reconstitué ses forces oui en fait là là
aussi clairement soupçonné de se servir
en fait des négociations comme d'un
écran de fumée pour pendant ce temps là
comme je disais veut marquer une pause
pour ses troupes et puis continuer le
pilonnage alors notamment de marioupol
et les français effectivement insiste
là-dessus comme le dit josiane et on
sait que ça fait partie de la discussion
et entre macro et poutine sans véritable
succès puisque les conceptions des
corridors humanitaires côté occidental
et côté rue ce ne sont pas les mêmes
donc il n'y a toujours pas d'accord mais
jean yves le drian d'ailleurs dans
l'interview à 10 ce qui serait très
significatif pour le coup ce serait un
cessez le feu
à marioupol bon on imagine difficilement
que vladimir poutine a aidé en ce sens
puisque toute sa stratégie semble au
contraire de tout faire à n'importe quel
prix puisque marioupol et déjà
effectivement une ville martyre on
estime que 80% de la ville a été
détruite pour s'emparer de marioupol et
assurer enfin se continua montre le
donbass et la crimée et pouvoir affirmer
à ce moment là qu'il a eu des gains
territoriaux là à ce moment là il aura
quelques choses en main et l'a peut-être
acceptera-t-il de négocier avec l'autre
interrogation concernant le sort réservé
à odessa même si les choses sont
compliquées de ce point de vue là mais
vallières cottigny les dents quand même
la situation de tout dirigeant
autoritaire qui se lance dans une guerre
il lui faut des gars territoriaux parce
que il a beaucoup étudié crédit qui est
en jeu il a beaucoup étudié l'histoire
il sait très bien que les dictateurs ou
les personnalité autoritaire on va dire
quand il se lance dans une guerre quand
ils perdent aide en général ça se
termine pas bien pour mes l'année de la
différence étant que il ya beaucoup de
facteurs qui entraînent vers une crise
longue d'abord il ya une lien une
opération militaire mais qui donne pas
les résultats escomptés parce qu'on ce
qu'on disait serre que je pense que du
côté russe on se rend compte du côté des
généraux de l'appareil on se rend compte
que qu'une prise de contrôle complète de
l'ukraine n'est plus là scénario jouable
donc il ya scénario 2
le dombass chose avec moi c'est dans son
acception large mais même la bataille de
desa serait travailliste et le sud lui
même la bataille de desa sans
pratiquement on imagine l'importance des
moyens qui seraient mis pâle pâle elle
le play par les militaires russes pour
conquérir et tenir un mini est encore
une fois administrés qui on va mettre
comme emballe métriques ça donc ça c'est
le première chose la deuxième chose
c'est que il ya le deuil à ce qui se
passe en occident de la solidité de
l'alliance est ce qu'on va tenir est ce
qu'on va livrer les armes est ce qu'on
va en livrer suffisamment est-ce qu'on
va tenir face à cette problématique
énergétique qui est pas du tout
négligeable ce que vous avez vu
aujourd'hui les chiffres de l'inflation
enfin c'est surréaliste les gens s'en
rendent peut être pas vraiment compte
encore mais on parle de 9 % 10 %
d'inflation c'est pas arrivé depuis 40
ans ça va avoir un impact sur les
opinions publiques donc ça ça joue aussi
il ya tout ce qui se passe autour c'est
à dire le reste du monde qui regarde
cette guerre comme une guerre excusez
moi une guerre entre autres blancs cessé
entre l'otan et la russie l'afrique la
moitié des sciences de l'hémisphère nord
oui l'amérique latine ya tout là il ya
beaucoup d'interrogations sur ce qui se
passe et donc on voit bien que tout est
en mouvement
on n'a pas atteint ce point où les
poules et les
les acteurs de la crise se disent il
faut un intérêt mutuel à l'ivoirité et
encore une fois la question de la
neutralité de l'ukraine justement c'est
une fournissait à chaque fois le l'outil
de la transition qui fout on va voir je
ferai à dire ici alors je vous
précisément nous c'est comme si on vous
avait briefé avons écouté ce qu'ils
avaient à dire justement j'aime l'odeur
sur cette question la neutralité
je ne vais pas négocier à la place des
ukrainiens c'est aux ukrainiens de
négocier avec la russie on connaît les
sujets de négociation
neutralité garantie niveau de
démilitarisation de l'ukraine tel de
l'ukraine territoire qu'elle statue sur
le don basse et la question de la crimée
avec en plus de ça la nécessité d'un
cessez le feu à quel moment et la
nécessité aussi d' un agenda de retrait
progressif des forces russes c'est tout
ça le paquet de négociations mais ça
fait trois semaines que c'est tout ça
est pour l'instant à part le président
s'est inscrit la seule initiative forte
qui a été prise c'est celle par laquelle
il a annoncé sa volonté de faire en
sorte que l'ukraine devienne un pays
notre ce sont les mêmes sujets oui sont
abordés régulièrement par les
délégations russe et les délégation
ukrainienne depuis trois semaines avec
une avance est un acte politique lourd
qui était posée par le présent et lens
qui consiste à dire moi je suis d'accord
pour qu'on travaille sur un concept de
neutralité de l'ukraine oui mais jeudi
en même temps au delà de la neutralité
dont il faut définir le contenu pour
l'instant ce n'est pas le cas il me faut
des garanties de sécurité ce qui est
normal donc posons le réfléchissons
garanties de sécurité et pour l'instant
il n'ya pas d'acceptation ni du propre
premier principe ni du second
garanties de sécurité supposent aussi
référendum ensuite en ukraine et pour
cela et bien il faut l'intégrité
territoriale donc cessez le feu
autrement dit la neutralité ne serait
que l'aboutissement d'un processus et ne
peut en être le préalable bruno daroux
est ce que ça ne bloque pas finalement
toute solution politique oui si c'est
pour le moment c'est ça qui bloque parce
que ça en fait ce que vous venez de dire
est ce que vient de dire jean yves le
drian c'est la neutralité de l'offrir
l'acceptation côté ukrainien ce qui est
effectivement un pas politique important
et diplomatique de la part du président
et même ce qui met les conditions elle
qu'on a décrites sont ukrainiennes c'est
à dire à cesser le feu un retrait des
troupes russes les ukrainiens disent
même retrait des troupes russes sur
leurs positions d'avant le 24 février
tirs d'avant l'invasion dont vous voyez
dire qu'en fait ils dégagent totalement
de l'ukraine et à ce moment-là
organisation d'un référendum national
donc nul doute que du côté de la
présidence russe on estime aussi qu'il
n'y a pas de percée parce que ces
conditions là bas ne sont pas
satisfaisantes pour la partie russe
ziad
on a le sentiment quand même qui fait un
pas important et l'ins qui met
effectivement dans les faits on voit
difficilement vladimir poutine accepter
cette neutralité l'un avec ses codicille
et parce que le parce que c'est le fond
de la discussion depuis des années c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas cette guerre qui
vous pas venir la question de qualité du
reste en réalité la question de la
neutralité ou deux parce qu'il ya
d'autres pays qui sont concernés par ce
débat ces terres tout tous les pays qui
sont dans la sphère russe et en
particulier les pays euro russe on va
dire c'est qu'ils sont entre les deux
sont touchés par cette question de la
neutralité et la finlande aussi est
touchée par l'action de la neutralité
donc c'est pas c'est pas un concept
qu'on a mis sur la table ce matin en
faisant comme on le fait et puis
deuxièmement il ya la question des
garanties quand vous dites les européens
ou les américains où la france va
garantir la neutralité de l'ukraine ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que si
demain quelqu'un attaque l'ukraine et
suivez mon regard pour une autre raison
pour un autre d'un ace qu'on est dans le
cadre d'un accord type autant article 5
est ce qu'on est dans un autre cas c'est
ce que nous avons dû grandir c'est ce
que demandent les ukrainiens alors
justement sur l'engagement et hormis la
chine quand même sûrement possible
demain de 21 sur la france et des autres
puissances occidentales quid en cas d'
usage d'armes chimiques par la russie en
ukraine et coûter
6,6 la russie utilise des armes non
conventionnelles de ce type et il faut
qu'ils s'attendent à des sanctions
massives très forte ils le savent on le
leur a déjà dit donc il faut qu'il
prenne en considération ces risques mais
on a vu en 2013 comment quand des armes
chimiques ont été utilisés en syrie tout
le monde les américains ont regardé
ailleurs est ce que vous ne craignez pas
que la même chose se reproduise je pense
que le président poutine s'est rendu
compte d'une chose
c'est l'unité et la fermeté et de
l'union européenne de l'ensemble des
pays et de la relation transatlantique
la solidité de l'alliance est aussi la
volonté de l'ensemble de ces pays
d'aider l'ukraine très fermement
à la fois par des sanctions à la fois
par de soutien financier mais aussi par
la livraison d'équipements militaires il
sait cela donc c'est à lui d'apprécier
les risques mais
c'est de sa responsabilité pas de la
nôtre on voit là toute la difficulté de
l'exercice comme on ne pas tracer de
ligne russe pour ne pas se retrouver
dans la situation de barack obama en
syrie tout en tentant de dissuader la
russie bah en fait il trace quand même
une ligne rouge parce que là on n'a pas
vu l'extrait il dit facile dit il y aura
des sanctions lourdes et massif il est
relancé en sanctions économiques bailly
les romans c'est un moment et il dit je
je je ne vous répondrai pas donc
paisiblement il sait pertinemment quel
type de sanctions seraient sans doute
notamment des sanctions économiques
sousse à des sanctions plus personnelle
contre vladimir poutine je ne sais pas
visiblement ils ont leur arsenal de
nouvelles sanctions plus lourdes et plus
massive mais à ce stade jean yves le
drian ne veut pas le dévoiler donc c'est
quand même une forme de lignes rouges
pour les russes qui qui sont prévenus on
ne peut pas agiter la dissuasion
militaire à ce stade en diable non elle
a été exclu dès le départ il y compris
en cas d' attaques non conventionnelles
d'usagé d'armes chimiques non il
apparaître sanctions et il a parlé d'
armes défensives les talking d'un
concept intéressant déjà livrés oui mais
on peut livrer plus si l'on peut en
donner plus on peut aller plus loin on
peut donner des choses plus précis mais
bon c'est quand même une drôle de notion
armes défensives les talents entre
défensives et offensives bon ils s'en
servent voilà non moi je pense qu'il ya
un facteur aussi qu'ils jouent dans
cette histoire très très très importante
c'est la personnalité de baden parce que
dans le cas de la syrie il ya eu le rôle
de obama le rôle du congrès qui a joué
en même temps et là on a quand même un
président américain qui utilise des mots
qui utilise des phrases qui a un
positionnement très prononcé boucher et
c est donc juste bayonne en 2013 sur la
syrie lui était
il le plus anti poutine j'allais dire
depuis longtemps il le fallait dit qu'il
la pratique et que donc je pense que la
position américaine là est plus tranché
et que encadrent effectivement dans
l'utilisation d'armes non
conventionnelles chimique extérieur est
il y aurait effectivement des sanctions
extrêmement lourdes mercy irène merci
également à vous bruno daroux voilà
c'était maison militaire c'est l analyse
et la réaction à l'entretien qu'a
accordé jean yves le drian à france24
entretien vous pourrez revoir à 23h
heure française non ce ou dans deux
minutes pour un nouveau journal
[Musique]